[Music]
ursula k le guin's short story on the
high marsh found in her fifth earthsea
book tales from earthsea centers around
this character who is named irioth and
goes by
several other
names traveling around as an animal
healer or cure
clearly somebody possessed of power but
a little lost in the world and we begin
with him
almost on the verge of getting lost up
on the mountain and then coming in into
the marshlands
in the we see this in the early darkness
of a winter day a traveler stood at the
windswept crossing of two paths neither
very promising mere cattle tracks among
the reeds and looked for some sign of
the way he should take at last
he came down the last slope of the
mountain he had seen houses here and
there out in the marshlands of village
not far away and it grows dark and then
he runs into a cow and he says are you
there my dear he spoke in the old speech
the language of the making
come along then ullah he said in the
heifer came a step or two towards him
towards her name which while he walked
up to meet her he made the big head he
made out the big head more by touch than
by sight stroking the silken dip between
her eyes scratching her forehead at the
roots of the nubbin horns beautiful you
are beautiful he told her breathing her
grassy breath leaning against her large
warmth will you lead me dear allah will
you lead me where i need to go
we learn one more important piece of
information he was fortunate in having
met a farm heifer not one of the roaming
cattle who would have only let him
deeper into the marshes and so what do
we see in this he's somebody who can in
fact communicate with the beasts he
speaks the old language that means that
he is a a wizard a perhaps a mage
somebody of power somebody of knowledge
and he's on familiar terms with him as
we're going to see a little bit later on
when he's contrasted against the cowboys
this is very important at the same time
he is somebody who is lost and is trying
to find his way
in the world he is led by this this
heifer um
to this this gate and he opens the gate
for and he stumbles across the dark
house yard to the door
he knocks on the door and then we get to
our second main character in this gift
who is going to
take him in and she is a 50 year old
something around that widow and very
hard worker who has an alcoholic brother
named barry and she takes him in
and says you know i'll i'll let you warm
yourself here he asks if there's an in
she says you can stay the night in our
place um and then you know maybe you'd
you'd come up with some payment for that
and she asked them what are you doing
here nobody comes here in the winter
what's going on
and he tells her
she said um you came over the mountain
he nodded whatever for
to come here
not many come to the high marsh peddlers
and such but not in winter
and then she she says why would you come
to the marsh she had a right to ask
having taken him in yet she felt a
discomfort in pressing the question and
here's where he says what's going on
i was told there is a murren among the
cattle here now that he wasn't all
locked up with cold his voice was
beautiful he talked like the tail
tellers when they spoke the parts of the
heroes and the dragon lords maybe he was
a teller or a singer but no the murren
he had said there is
i may be able to help the beasts you're
a cure he nodded then you'll be more
than welcome the plague is terrible
among the cattle and getting worse so a
mirin is not an actual disease like
anthrax or something like that it's just
a general catch-all term like saying i
hear the cattle have got some cold or
the plague or the flu or something like
that and they are having some really
serious problems with that
we find that he has a very
different approach to the animals than
everybody else does
so we we are told by
the cowboys
here we go
he does that the cowboy said to gift
talks at them he was amazed disdainful
is he curing the cattle she asked well
he can't lift the marine all at once but
it seems like he can cure a beast if he
gets to it before the staggers begin and
those not struck yet he says he can keep
it off him so the master's sending him
about all about the range to do what can
be done it's too late for
many
and we find that as uh he's
out there working with the cattle the
cattle let them walk let him walk among
them
wild as they were and having nothing for
men's hands but castration and butchery
he had a pleasure and their trust in him
a pride in it he should not but he did
if he wanted to touch one of the great
beasts he had only to stand and speak to
it a little while in the language of
those who do not speak ullah he said
naming them elu eloah they stood big
indifferent sometimes one looked at him
for a long time sometimes one came to
him with its easy loose majestic tread
and breathed into its open palm
all those
who came to him he could cure he laid
his hands on them on the stiff-haired
hot flanks and neck and sent the healing
into his hands with the words of power
spoken over and over after a while the
beast would give a shake or toss its
head a bit or step on then he would drop
his hands and stand there drained and
blank for a while then there would be
another one big curious shyly bold muddy
coated with the sickness in it like a
prickling a tingling a hotness in his
hands a dizziness elu he would say and
walk to the beast and lay his hands upon
it until they felt cool as if a mountain
stream ran through them so he is using
magical power and knowledge to
cure all of these cattle some
that can be cured others it's gone too
far he also tells the cowboys you need
to boil the water you're drinking and
don't eat that tongue from that cattle
who's died or you'll be dead in a year
from now so it's not just experiential
knowledge of the healing itself it's
also an understanding
of what is going on so this is pretty
important he
could in fact
be a
notable person
in this village
as a matter of fact he's a little bit
too good as the women a little bit later
are going to say
when gift is talking with alder's wife
tawny and some others
gift says are the cattle he touched
keeping a foot then
and she says so far as we can tell see
they are and no new sickenings he's a
true sorcerer tawny gifts that very
earnest i know i know it
and then tawny says that's the trouble
love and you know it this is no man for
a pl this is no place for a man like
that
whoever he is is none of our business
but why did he come here that's what you
have to ask and gift says to cure the
beasts
so they could have a great boon from him
but they also distrust him as well
because they're used to things not being
well done in their little village
uriath himself is a broken man as we
find and not broken in a simple single
way
so
there's this great passage
he was mad and she didn't know what
possessed her to let him stay yet she
could not fear or distrust him
what did it matter if he was mad
he was gentle notice the contrast there
and he wasn't so mad as all that madden
patches
mad at moments nothing in him was whole
not even his madness he couldn't
remember the name he had told her and he
told people in the village to call him
otak he probably couldn't remember her
name either he always called her
mistress but maybe that was his courtesy
she called him sir and courtesy and
because neither gully nor otak the two
used names that he's given seemed names
well suited to him an otak she'd heard
was a little animal with sharp teeth and
no voice but there were no such
creatures on the high marsh she thought
perhaps his talk of coming here to cure
the cattle sickness was one of the mad
bits he didn't act like the cures who
came by with remedies and spells and
salves for the animals but this is
proven wrong when he goes out after he's
starting to feel better and actually
starts curing the animals
a little bit earlier in the story as he
wakes up for the first day
we read
he woke as he always did in his room in
the great house he did not understand
why the ceiling was low and the air
smelled fresh but sour and cattle were
bawling outside
so he's used to waking up at roque in
the great house for you know the school
of uh mages
and he's
this is established by great habit you
could say
he's waking up and finding himself in an
unfamiliar place and not just an
unfamiliar place
as an unfamiliar person
he had to lie still and come back to
this other place
and this other man
whose use name he couldn't remember
though he had said it last night to a
heifer or a woman he knew his true name
but it was no good here wherever here
was or anywhere
so every
time he's waking up he has to figure out
who the hell he is
and what's going on we also find that he
doesn't set a price
before taking on this extensive work of
healing cattle and he really gets
cheated by
uh the the
you know cattle baron of sorts we could
say who is is out there who gives him
mere copper pennies rather than the
ivory coin coins or counters that would
have been his share
he spends 10 days out
in the cold healing the cattle going
from place to place
working through the herds
and the cowboys actually leave him his
escorts before too long he suggests that
the food will last longer if they just
go on their way and then he comes back
10 days later totally exhausted
it like the the book says it took him
six more days to get through the big
herds in the eastern marshes the last
two days he spent riding out to scatter
scattered groups of cattle that had
wandered up towards the feet of the
mountain many were not infected yet and
he could protect him
the hinny carried him bare back and made
the going easy but there was nothing
left for him to eat when he rode back to
the village he was light-headed in weak
kneed he took a long time getting home
from alder stable where he left the
hinny emmer greeted him and scolded him
and tried to make him eat but he
explained that he could not eat yet as i
stayed there in the sickness and the
sick fields i felt sick after a while
i'll be able to eat again and this is
where she asked did you did you set a
price and he says no i i didn't
then we find a confrontation because he
goes to get his money from alder we find
a confrontation with another
sorcerer because alder actually wants
him to do more work he says maybe you'll
be looking at my yearlings over the long
pond pastures the next day or so and
iriath says no sans herd was going down
fast and i left i'm needed there he says
oh no you're not master otak while you
were out in the east range a sorcerer
cure came by a fellow that's been here
before from the south coast and sand
hired him you'll work for me and you'll
be paid well better than copper maybe if
the beasts fare well and so he walks
over to san's house and he runs into
this new
sorcerer
master sunbri bright brought up to deal
with the murren
and we have this description here the
sorcerer came out from behind son his
name was ayath the power in him was
small tainted corrupted by ignorance and
misuse and lying but the jealousy in him
was like a stinging fire i've been
coming doing business here for some 10
years looking eerie up and down a man
walks in from somewhere north takes my
business some people would quarrel with
that a quarrel of sorcerers is a bad
thing if you're a sorcerer a man of
power that is i am all the good people
here know that well eria doesn't want a
quarrel
but he's finding himself getting drawn
into it
and
iriath
speaks you have to go back as he said
back his left hand struck down on the
air like a knife and ayath fell backward
against the chair staring they're about
to enter into a magical
battle and erioth
starts raising spells to deal with him
and then pulls back
and effectively has a
seizure
gift has to or
has to come and
take him back to her home
and help
nurse him back to health again
so
the villagers shook their heads gift was
a brave woman there was such a thing as
being too brave or brave in the wrong
way or in the wrong place
nobody
should ought to meddle with sorcery that
ain't born to it nor with sorcerers you
forget that they seem the same as other
folks but they ain't like other folks
seems there's no harm in a cure that's
all fine but cross one and there you are
fires and shadows and curses and falling
down in fifths
so
this is where we're left at about the
midpoint
of the
story we have
erioth he's clearly a gifted healer
but there's something
quite off about him something
mysterious
something that we can't quite place
gift emmer thinks that he's gentle but
he was ready to
do in the other sorcerer so who is this
man we'll find out
as we move forward into the story
you